the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome to 507 biochemistry
online I'm dr. bodanza de leche this
video is about pyridoxal phosphate or
PLP an essential metabolism cofactor
derived from vitamin b6 all animals are
auxotrophic for PLP meaning they need to
supplement their diet with vitamin b6 in
order to survive PLP is one of the most
ancient cofactors and surprisingly it
can catalyze chemical transformation
such as a transamination even without an
enzyme PLP is actually involved in a
staggering number of biochemical
transformations this video summarizes
the most important reactions involving
PLP that you will see in 507 and will
also show you how to write the complete
curve there are mechanisms for these
transformations let's talk about PLP
catalyzed reactions as we just mentioned
PLP is the cofactor derived from vitamin
b6 this cofactor is very important for a
number of reactions in this course we're
going to look particularly at the
transamination reaction this is a
crucial reaction for the metabolism of
all amino acids and we're also going to
encounter this reaction when we
replenish the intermediates in the TCA
cycle what we call anaplerotic reactions
and we're also going to see PRP involved
in reactions in the Mallett aspartate a
shuttle that transfers redox equivalents
reducing equivalents between
mitochondria and cytosol let's take a
look at the structure of vitamin b6 or
also known as paradox seen
this is the molecule that we ingest when
they get our daily vitamin supplement
now in the body this gets oxidized to
form intermediate called pyridoxal
notice that I'll de hit a group here
which is going to be the business end of
the molecule now the active cofactor PLP
it's actually the phosphorylate version
of paradox al this requires one molecule
of ATP and the enzyme paradoxical kinase
and we get p LP or paradoxical 5
phosphate the name PLP comes from the
initials as outlined here now this
nitrogen on the pyridine ring tends to
be protonated because it's PKA it's
close to physiological ph between 6 & 7
now for the rest of this presentation
we're going to be abbreviating this
phosphate group as such and throughout
the course now a related molecule is
pyridoxamine 5 phosphate which we'll see
it's an intermediate in the mechanism of
PLP catalyzed reactions also known as
PNP now notice PNP has an amine group
here which replaces the aldehyde group
which is the business end of the
molecule now in all reactions with PLP
this cofactor it's actually covalently
bound to the enzyme that uses it
typically there's a lysine in the active
side of the enzyme as you remember
lysine as an amine group and this can
form a schiff base with the aldehyde the
reaction proceeds in two steps
first we form a tetrahedral intermediate
as such and then we form the ship space
so this will be the enzyme bound PLP and
this is where all the PRP catalyze
reactions start let's take a closer look
as a transamination reaction termination
reaction occurs between an amino acid
and an alpha keto acid we have here
amino acid one where we highlighted the
amine group and alpha keto acid 2 as you
can see there's a keto group next to the
carboxyl now in the transamination
reaction catalyzed by PRP the amine
group moves from the amino acid to the
keto carbon of the alpha keto acid and
we obtain a new alpha Q acid and a new
amino acid so in effect the PRP
catalyzed transamination reaction
facilitates the transfer of the amine
group from an amino acid to an alpha
keto acid now this reaction actually
occurs in two steps in the first step
the amino acid transfers the group to
the cofactor itself
so if you remember from the previous
slide the PMP contains an amino group
and that will actually contain this
amino group that was taken from the
amino acid one now in the second step
PMP will transfer its amino group to a
different alpha keto acid to generate a
new amino acid now there are enzymes for
virtually every single amino acid that
can accomplish this first transformation
where by using PLP they transfer the
amine group and form an alpha keto acid
and the PMP now in the second part of
the reaction however the alpha keto acid
2 is typically alpha ketoglutarate or
oxaloacetate so in this case not any
alpha keto acid can can function alpha
ketoglutarate or oxaloacetate now let's
take a look at an example for example
glutamate it's gonna be our amino acid
and oxaloacetate it's going to be our
alpha keto acid and an appeal peak
catalyzed transformation we will obtain
the alpha-keto acid corresponding to
glutamate which is alpha ketoglutarate
and the amino acid corresponding to
oxaloacetate which is aspartate
this enzyme that catalyzes this
transformation is in fact ubiquitous and
it's found both in the liver in the
muscles and it is in fact a we can call
it depending on the products we can call
it aspartate transaminase or glutamate
oxaloacetate transaminase in fact if we
find this in the in the bloodstream this
enzyme acts as a biomarker and it tells
us about some damage that might have
occurred in muscle or liver which forced
the cells to spill out their contents
this biomarker is you'll often see as s
Cox serum glutamate oxaloacetate
transaminase and this is one of the the
biomarkers that are measured in blood
tests that tells us about heart disease
or liver disease
let's take a look at the mechanism of
the transamination reaction and in
particular we're going to take a look
look at part one which as we discussed
before the amino acid reacts is PLP to
form an alpha keto acid and PMP here is
our cofactor PLP covalently bound to the
lysine in the active site of the enzyme
via a shift base and here is our amino
acid starting material it's in the first
step the lysine that forms the shift
base was a cofactor is going to be
replaced by the amine functionality of
the amino acid and it will form a new
shift base was the cofactor this starts
with the amine group attack on the
paradoxical carbon to form a tetrahedral
intermediate
and following an additional proton
transfer the lysine can be kicked off to
form a new shift pace so far we have
started with the ship space
corresponding to the PLP bound to the
enzyme and we now obtained a and
cofactor forming a shift base with the
incoming amino acid 1 so this portion of
the mechanism is called transamination
because we're starting was one amine and
we're forming a different ami now let's
take a look at the Alpha proton attached
to the Alpha carbon which within a
highlight here this program is now in
between two carbonyl like groups here is
the carboxyl group and here is the shift
base group so it becomes acidic enough
they can be removed by an active side
base for example the lysine in the
active site this will generate a
carbonate alpha carbon this carbon ion
can only form because it is resonance
stabilized and indeed the PLP ring
system it's highly conjugated and it's a
good electron sink
for this Cabana we can write in fact
many different resonance structures
let's take a look at one of them this
symbol denotes resonance structures
notice in this structure the positive
charge on the pyridine nitrogen is now
gone
and highlights the fact that this is a
good electron sink and the ring now
looks more like a quinol that's why we
call this a quintet structure or
intermediate this quinidine structure
shows us a glimpse into how the reaction
will proceed because the alpha carbon
now it's doubly bonded to a nitrogen
which anticipates how this alpha carbon
will become a keto group and a product
the reaction will be an alpha keto acid
what happens the quinoid structure can
be reprimanded heated carbon of burlock
cell so highlighted these facts these
structures are in fact resonance
structures I'm going to put them in
brackets
so let's take a look at what happened in
this past a couple of steps so we had an
alpha proton there was fairly acidic it
was able to being removed by the active
side lysine and then this proton came
back to a different position so all just
happened in this a couple of steps was a
proton transfer now looking at this
intermediate we can see that in fact the
shift space or the amine of the PNP form
of the cofactor and the alpha-keto acid
corresponding to amino acid 1 so via
hydrolysis reaction these two can come
apart so the first step in activated
water molecule attacks alpha carbon
forming a tetrahedral intermediate
and one more proton transfer and we can
kick off the pyridoxamine form of the
cofactor
and notice we obtain PMP and the
alpha-keto acid corresponding to the to
the amino acid 1 this last step it's in
fact just a hydrolysis reaction of a
shift base
now let's take a look at the second part
of the pop3 simulation reaction the part
one left us off with formation of PMP so
in this second part PMP will react with
a new alpha keto acid to Gen regenerate
PLP and a new amino acid in fact this
part of the mechanism it's the exact
reverse of part one here is PMP and our
alpha keto acid the first step we're
going to form as we've gotten used so
far to a new a mean between the keto
group of the avocado acid and the main
group of PRP as usual first we're going
to get a tetrahedral intermediate and
one more proton transfer and we can kick
off the oh wait group to form the amine
now this portion of the reaction is in
fact eme information which is the
reverse of the hydrolysis step that we
saw in part 1 now as you remember
there's an active site lysine which can
act as a general base and it's going to
deprotonate one of these two protons on
that paradox al the reason we can form
this carbon and here is because this
negative charge is delocalized
throughout the entire ring system and
let's show one important resonance
structure
which is none other than the Quinta made
structure we saw before just as before
the lysine the protonated lysine can now
donate a proton on a different position
for example the alpha carbon of the
alpha keto acid
as you can see here now the proton is on
the alpha position and now where this
starts to look more like the ship's base
form by the an amino acid was the PLP
version of the cofactor so from here on
onwards we're just going to substitute
the pob the amino acid bound to the PRP
with the active site lysine in a
transamination reaction that we saw
before
so first the lysine can attack at this
carbon
forming a tetrahedral intermediate and
then the following some proton transfer
we can kick off the amino acid and
generate the Schiff space corresponding
to the PRP cofactor bound to the enzyme
so here we have PLP enzyme bond and the
new amino acid - we mentioned PRP is a
very versatile cofactor so let's take a
look what other reactions
besides transamination can PRP catalyze
what an interesting reaction used
especially by bacteria is our simulation
this involves taking an L amino acid for
example L alanine and converting it via
PLP catalyzed reaction to d-alanine this
is important reaction for bacteria as
they incorporate the alanine into the
cell walls which makes it very hard to
recognize by the immune system and makes
it very hard to digest by the host
proteases let's take a look at a key
intermediate in the PRP catalyzed
reaction as before l-alanine is going to
react with the PRP bound to the enzyme
and it's going to form an amine
here we're highlighting the
stereochemistry of the alpha hydrogen
and here is our active active site
lysine as we've seen before
this alpha hydrogen is acidic enough
they can be removed by the lysine and
it's going to form a carbon iron at this
position
now this carbon and as we've seen before
is able to form because the charge is in
fact delocalized through the entire
system of the pyridoxal ring so for this
structure we can we can write a number
of resonance structures which we're not
going to mention here now this carbon
ion could be repro nated and here we had
a certain the hydrogen was pointing up
on top of the plane of the page but we
can reap relate it from the bottom and
that will change the stereochemistry at
this carbon if that representation helps
us from the bottom we will obtain the
ship's base corresponding to the D Ally
so by being able to generate this carb
anion at the Alpha position the pupae
reaction and cofactor allows the
inversion of the configuration at the
alpha carbon
converting the l-alanine to do now
another interesting reaction that
requires PRP it's decarboxylation here
we're looking at an amino acid for
example glutamate the PRP catalyzed
reaction it can lose this co2 group and
form this molecule which is called
gamma amino butyric acid or GABA this is
in fact a very important
neurotransmitter an inhibitory
neurotransmitter that is required in the
brain
let's take a look how this
decarboxylation is catalyzed by PLP as
always ever seen so far the glutamate we
react with PLP bound in the active site
of the enzyme to form a shift base here
is the shift things like that now
instead of deprotonating at the Alpha
position the co2 is activated to leave
because it will leave behind a carbon
such as that
then as we seen before a carbon inform a
disposition can delocalized throughout
the entire paradox I'll ring and
therefore it's stabilizing the case it's
long enough and we're not gonna draw but
there you can imagine there are a number
of different resonance structures now
this carbon
it gets protonated quickly by a general
acid and what generates this structure
which is just the shift base
corresponding to the gamma amino butyric
acid with PLP and now from here a
transamination where the active site
lysine will remove the PLP and free up
the gaba products of the reaction in
this video we talked about PLP catalyzed
reactions PLP is the cofactor that comes
from vitamin b6
here's vitamin b6 what we call paradox
seen which is the molecule that we we
find in our vitamin pills now in the
body paradox informs paradox al which is
activated to form paradox al 5 phosphate
or PLP and typically when it reacts PLP
is found as a ship's base bound in the
active site via a lysine PLP is very
important for transamination reactions
which are essential for the metabolism
all amino acids we have seen the
transamination reaction where an amino
acid one reacts with alpha keto acid to
and via PLP catalyzed reaction forms an
alpha keto acid one an amino acid to
essentially transferring the group the
amino group from the amino acid to the
alpha keto acid the reaction occurs in
two steps where first the amino acid is
transferred to PLP to form P and
then PMP transfers this group the amino
group back to a alpha keto acid to
generate a new amino acid as we saw the
mechanism transamination involves
multiple steps the first step is a trans
emanation reaction where the shift space
that's formed between the active site
license and the PLP is becomes a shift
base between the incoming amino acid and
PLP next we have a proton transfer which
is allowed by the ability of the PLP
ring to stabilize the negative charge
and move the proton from the Alpha
position to somewhere on the on the PLP
ring via generate the quinoid structure
and finally the the resulting shift base
is hydrolyzed to generate PMP and an
alpha keto acid in the second part of
the reaction PMP now reacts with alpha
keto acid to form a new shift base and
then the proton transfer happens in
Reverse via again the coordinate
structure to generate the shift base
corresponding to the PLP and the new
amino acid to which via transamination
reaction will generate amino acid 2 and
the PLP enzyme finally we mentioned the
PLP is very versatile and it can
catalyze other reactions such as
reservation for example switching the
configuration at the alpha carbon from
l-alanine to the alanine or
decarboxylation generating alpha amino
butyric acid or GABA an important
neurotransmitter from glutamate